bonjour avez vous dire en guise de très
court préambule que là aussi il ne faut
pas se fier aux apparences mais deux
invités sont également femmes elles ont
toutes les deux une passion à ses
dévorante pour l'astrologie elles sont
passées d'ailleurs du violon d'ingres à
l'activité professionnelle et elles ont
toutes les deux publié leurs oeuvres
complètes enfin loin d'être complète
puisque il y as devant chacune plusieurs
livres et que ce sont des livres qui ont
trait à l'astrologie et pourtant et
pourtant mesdames vous n'êtes pas
d'accord il ya un propos que j'ai relevé
que vous avez tenu récemment françoise
hardy vous avez dit je regrette que
tessier vous avez oublié le prénom mais
c'est pas grave ça prouve oui
je regrette que tessier
déconsidère l'astrologie et donne une
image de marque catastrophique de notre
profession je n'avais pas appris cela
oui c'est un petit peu excessif je ne
m'exprime généralement pas dans des
termes comme ça
c'est vrai que je déplore que elizabeth
teissier
fasse croire que l'astrologie permet de
faire des prédictions je déplore cela
parce que c'est faux et parce que c'est
donner une fausse idée de l'astrologie
faire croire que l'on peut prévoir un
accident de voiture un divorce des
choses comme ça c'est absolument faux
quand on fait de l'astrologie
sérieusement et honnêtement comme je
sais le faire vous êtes en train de dire
je suis pas honnête c'est ça ou alors
d'abord vous n'êtes pas honnête c'est
presque enfin ils vont écouter vous
permettez je vais pourrait presque pire
c'est sinon ça veut dire vous êtes
incompétent ah oui on allait jouer
contre la malhonnêteté l'incompétence
abbas il est toujours très mesuré dans
ses propos
[Musique]
j'ai décidé de pas m'énerver parce que
je considère que moi j'ai fait mes
preuves et vous non vous êtes une
dilettante dans l'astrologie pour vous
est une nouvelle venue vous avez le
temps de faire votre chemin
effectivement vous allez regarder en
permanence force prédictions qui étaient
toutes fausses on ne revient pas
[Applaudissements]
un mot bon d'abord il faut pas confondre
vos propres possibilités en matière de
prévisions et les possibilités en
général de l'astrologie car à travers
l'histoire je ne parle même pas de moi
voyez vous contrairement à ce que vous
dites mon ego je veux dire c'est pas
toujours ce que je fais passer en
premier pour ce que je reconnais mes
erreurs quand je me trompe ce qui n'est
pas le cas de tout le monde dans
l'histoire il ya de nombreuses
astrologue trop nombreux ils sont foule
qui ont fait des prévisions juste et des
prévisions quant à leur propre mort par
exemple comme nostradamus la veille de
sa mort comme les angels il est
finalement il était prophète également
vous n'a rien à voir mais je continue
dans les articles ne répondra pas des
astronautes profite alors des
astrologues evangeline adams et une
astrologue américaine très connu qui a
pour la première fois à vulgariser la
solution en amérique et elle a prévu sa
propre mort par exemple au jour près et
c'est bon par exemple la femme de du
guesclin pour parler de la france
profonde comme un beau monde et la femme
de du guesclin qui s'appelait raguenel
typhaine a fait toutes les prévisions
pour son futur mari savez pour ça qu'il
a épousée le fameux du guesclin parce
qu'elle lui disais quand est-ce qu'il
fallait qu'il se bat et il gagne et
quand quand il suivait ses conseils et
la seule fois où il a re vous n'avez
rien comme exemple ici ce qui était faux
il y en a beaucoup d'abord j'ai prévu
tchernobyl mais à d'autres astrologue
que prévu des tas de choses andré
barbeau a fait des prévisions
extraordinairement et en particulier la
fin du monde pour 1994 n'ont jamais été
très déçu non j'avais prédit la fin du
monde non mais je ne veux pas dire de
mal de la santé en grève darbo il faut
deux messieurs saisi la liste des
prédictions foncé il faudrait être
stupide pour dire que andré barbeau il
faudrait y prétendre qu'il est stupide
pour soupçonner qu'il ait pu imaginer de
prévoir la fin du monde parce que vous
comprenez tout à 5,84 on prend trop de
réunions il a vu un homme nu il a
intégré mondial gagne jamais à prévoir
la fin du monde est en augmentation mais
à troisième guerre mondiale ce qui
revient pratiquement jamais chanté
ensemble parce que vous vous parler
ensemble
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas que vous avez j'aurais pu
venir si j'avais daigné me défendre avec
noir sur blanc mais je considère que
madame hardy justement n'est pas comme
elle n'est pas considérée par les
astrologues et je me suis en qu'ils de
cela récemment je pourrais vous citer
des noms mais je vais pas faire cela ce
soir la déviation adro non même pas non
parce qu'on m'a permis mais les
astrologues ne me considère pas comme
une des leurs parce que vous êtes
nouvelle venue vous le vous ferez
peut-être votre chemin mais ce que je ne
comprends pas c'est votre arrivée elle
ne me considère pas non plus à des
remparts ne me concerne pas parce que
voyez vous ce qui se passe c'est que moi
quand même ça fait dix ans que je fais
de l'astrologie vous êtes en train
d'enfoncer des portes ouvertes
actuellement parce que vous venez
prêcher l'astrologie scientifiquement ça
fait dix ans que je dis que la sonnerie
est une science et maintenant vous
semblez découvrir des choses que je
comprends d'ailleurs parce que les
néophytes semble toujours découvrir des
choses il croit que les autres ne les
ont pas découverte avant lui je ne
découvre on va les shows et des
prévisions en effet faire une astrologie
intelligente des fêtes et ou alors c'est
tout via les fai borné alors attendez
attendez je crois que ce que j'ai cru
comprendre jeunes par exemple dans l
tout ça c'est noir sur blanc médard et
puis vous avez vu aussi que me n'ont pas
sauvé ce projet en 1985 monsieur chirac
serait victime d'un attentat 83 ans j'ai
dit qu'il y avait un risque y avait des
rythmes et les milieux ton temps dérive
n'y a pas tout le temps des risques vous
devriez savoir c'est en tant qu
astrologue qui n'a pas tout le temps des
risques comment pouvez vous dire c'est
là encore même le faire vous allez quand
même pour lui faire un procès parce que
nous gardons de noah politique
non
et en plus je me sens bleu madame
françoise hardy que vous faites des
prévisions sur rmc je fais de la pub en
ce moment pour vous alors vous êtes
allés avec jean je ne sais pas parler
familièrement qu'en fait les explosions
la nuance qui est extrêmement importante
entre prévisions et prédictions se fait
très vite effectivement ce raid voir des
climats mais on ne peut pas faire de
prédiction s'est dit que c'était débile
de faire des prévisions j'ai maintenant
que je parle de prédiction j'ai dit à ma
tendance caractère éventuellement tandis
que il isabelle tessier si je comprends
bien pure hypothèse de travail va
davantage vers des événements précis et
donc prendre davantage de risques que
vous oui j'essaye de les cerner les
événements et ce par tous au
conditionnel c'est partout sans
condition ce jeudi pour rester à cesser
la rue dans un oui mais c'est normal
c'est normal philippaerts ce qu'elles
pouvaient ils ont je ne considère pas
que j'aie la science infuse en plus des
cons il s'agit de science conjecturale
des conséquences sur l'avenir que ce
soit l'économie politique la
météorologie la psychologie la médecine
on ne peut parler qu'au conditionnel
l'astrologie aussi alors un petit détail
parce qu'avant de venir comme je le fais
d'ailleurs toujours quand je vous vois
c'est à dire tous les 5 ou 10 ans j'ai
consulté mon horoscope qui paraît sous
votre signature j'ai vu que la lune me
mettrais de bonne humeur le 27 alors je
voudrais comprendre pourquoi vous
voudriez comprendre la lune me l'a dit à
ce moment-là fera un angle harmonique
avec votre soleil
alors vous faites donc des horoscopes
françoise hardy je fais un horoscope
quotidien qui est d'ailleurs rédigé par
jean pierre nicolas pour radio
monte-carlo parce que c'est une demande
de radio monte carlo qui fait le
perroquet on
ne sait répondre répondre à cette
demande nous permet de tenter de faire
savoir et le dire les divisions ayant un
jour au lendemain sans jamais fait ça
c'est curieux de se dire astrologues et
de dire les textes des autres
astrologues voyez ce que je veux je
trouve ça un peu bizarre oui c'est un
travail qui est excessivement fastidieux
comme vous le savez qui en plus ne
correspond pas à grand chose puisque on
se base uniquement sur l'identité de ce
n'est absolument pas personnaliser et il
se trouve que je suis un j'ai la
possibilité actuellement je n'aurais
peut-être pas toujours de refuser les
travaux qui me paraissent trop
fastidieux troupe emmerdant pour être
vulgaire et le tout est de savoir par
quel jeu le jeu les faits parce que jean
pierre nicolas était d'accord pour
rédiger ce travail et en même temps
répondre à cette demande rade noté carlo
nous permettait d'avoir une émission
hebdomadaire au cours de laquelle nous
faisions un travail qui nous auraient
soit juste derrière ce qu'on veut nous
demande d'être à même la joie des bombes
ou publier des livres c'est pas
uniquement pour la gloire il était cool
ça des gens vivaient de l'astrologie bon
forcément me demande de faire
l'horoscope le matin je préfère le faire
moi que ce soit fait par pardo voilà de
toute façon fait que je voudrais juste
dire une chose au fond on aurait pu
couper court à tout cela au début parce
que je tourne en fait très triste si
vous voulez je trouve très triste très
triste
que l'astrologie
en fait l'image de l'astrologie souffre
de ce genre de
2 comment dire de rivalités intestines
rivalité dans un sens parce que moi je
n'ai aucune rivalité volonté du client
pour tout le monde non je dis que quand
je suis venu mois sur le marché à cette
embellie excusez moi du terme prosaïque
il y avait madame soleil jamais il ne me
serait venu à l'idée de la critique et
même si je n'étais pas de son avis parce
que je trouve qu'il ya une question
disons de solidarité oui oui oui qui le
canton du tournoi carcela cabarry et
puis quand on est bon ça se voit l'art
et puis quand on est bon tout ça sans il
ya du bien du travail pour toujours et
de soleil mais moi j'ai des fins je
défends mais parce que je trouve que
vous donnez une image de l'astrologie
qui est tout à fait incohérent qui
devrait te demander aux gens tousser en
avril faisons parce que oui heureusement
qu'il ya les faits pourquoi incohérent
mais parce que vous me permettez de fées
bond depuis quatre ans 170 mille
exemplaires parce que vous allez donc
sciences de faciliter donc s'en vont ben
si vous travaillez comme moi ben moi je
fais mes
ânes on m'a pas du tout ce bouquin
j'ai bien ces sept mois entier de
travail dont vous aviez prévu une
intervention chirurgicale à la fin de
septembre possibilité pour le simple
est-ce que je peux maintenant expliqué
c'est pas du tout parce que je veux me
justifier a posteriori mais je voudrais
dire ceci c'est que l'astrologie c'est
quand même et lahmada mardi vos
traitements la vie
c'est la science des symboles il faut
interpréter c'est pas seulement ça
derrière le symbole iag signal et c'est
ce dont vous tenez 50 vous ne tenez pas
compte des réalités concrètes
astronomique ou tard qu'il ya derrière
les symboles et vous
inviterai florian répondez moi le
parlement
le paf il a subi une intervention
chirurgicale oui oh non non non non pas
du tout mais je suis venu
je suis honnête malgré tout comment
j'allais peut-être prévu
philippe vous êtes trop sur les autres
os ou non mais je suis je vais vous dire
ce qui se passe tu avais prévu que fin
septembre et c'était fin septembre je
vous l'avais bien dit c'est peut-être
pour ça d'ailleurs que la date avait été
changé qu'il serait utile serait très
comment vous dire
vulnérables sur le plan à la fois
psychique et physique et moi je
considère et tous les spiritualistes les
gens qui croient un peu dans les choses
de l'esprit les psychologues seront
d'accord pour dire que bouvard a vécu sa
mort quelque part parce qu'elle refuse
[Applaudissements]
cette confusion m'honore mais maziade
dans la vie non non je vous ai rallonger
la vie c est ce que tu fais en tout cas
vous attendez pas le seul à finir si
l'on n'en sortira pas je pense que que
le pape assistant à cette fantastique
comment dire
à cette campagne de médias absolument
fantastique où il lisait dans tous les
journaux qu'il allait qu'il risquait de
mourir à s'avoue d'ailleurs non pas moi
facile grâce à vous et à vos semblables
ci avait pas eu nostradamus et et vous
n'avez des prix médians je ne m'étais
pas fondre
médias ne se serait pas en parler de ça
alors c'est donc c'est à cause du livre
de fort wood je n'ai pas vendu mon livre
je n'ai pas donner un retentissement
aussi important à cette histoire j'avais
fait de vie 85 répondait pas vous allez
toujours par des chemins de traverse la
question et précise le pape n'a pas subi
d'intervention chirurgicale mais
dites-vous il a subi une autre agression
et cette agression a vécu sa mort vous
en un peu responsables j'espère que non
oui c'est à dire que nous dire une
orbite shawn oui je voudrais dire
simplement que moi en tant que personne
intéressant comme beaucoup d'autres à
l'astrologie ça ne m'intéresse pas de
savoir si le pav victime d'un attentat
si monsieur chirac connaissent très bien
ça ne m'atteint absolument traçons
m'intéresse vu dans un stade avoir des
informations sur l'un de mes
conditionnement qui mène à comprendre un
petit peu plus un petit peu mieux
comment je fonctionne comment
fonctionnent les autres voilà vous
intéresser bien le caractère des
personnalités oui mais je dis je ne
s'est pas jouée par avance pour les
produits réduire les traits de
l'astrologie à ce qu'il peut arriver à
messieurs reggane ou autres grands de ce
monde je trouve ça déplorable
[Musique]